you've been talking a lot about your
green energy plans today with claims
that would create up to half a million
jobs in the next seven years so how do
you work that figure out
oh good morning Sophie look this is the
biggest Economic Opportunity in a
generation and that is why it is so
integral to Labor's economic policy and
our plans for government so the kind of
jobs we're talking about first of all
that is everything from an expansion of
offshore wind to solar to new technology
in terms of things like tidal and Marine
technology but also making sure if we're
going to drive electric vehicles we make
them here in the UK our green steel
policy to make sure the steel industry
can do the transition towards net zero
wherever you look there are
opportunities here other countries are
Desperately Seeking these and actually
are far ahead of us and we're blowing
this opportunity under this government
and that's why everything labor is
putting forward is about getting the
most of that getting the massive
potential benefits this country should
have flowing to it from this transition
Net Zero is about jobs good jobs for
every part of the country
so this is all part of your green
Prosperity plan you want to invest 28
billion pounds a year in that so you
know apologies for my maths over seven
years that works out at around 196
billion pounds a 196 billion pounds so
suddenly half a million jobs over seven
years
doesn't actually sound that great
because that would be you know just
under 400 000 pounds per job what how
does that work out so look at it in each
component so for instance the resources
we've allocated to the green steel
transition is around two billion pounds
of Investments required to do that
gigafactories will will gear up over
time depending on how quickly we can
deploy those things but I just want to
be clear about something this government
themselves because of the fact that we
aren't making batteries in the UK it
would be existential for the automotive
industry this government themselves will
have to put some money into this and
those are negotiations which I
understand are ongoing but the
difference between us and then is that
with them they're not public about this
you can't you can't download you can't
read their industrial strategy you have
to have it explain to you that it even
exists now for us it's an explicit it's
making a slightly different point here
about your plans and look you're the
guys who people think are going to be
number 10 after the next election so
it's right that we scrutinize your plans
uh not just the governments 28 billion
pounds year under the green Prosperity
plan to create half a million jobs in
the next seven years some people would
say that is an awful lot of money to be
spending
well I think if you look at the don't
look at the overall headline figure look
at the individual components we're
putting forward whether that's
insulating columns which brings down
bills provides jobs and gives greater
energy security to the UK whether it's
making sure we've got a steel industry
in the UK I don't think we can be the
first major developed economy that has
no domestic steel industry I think if
you look at the strength of the
automotive sector in the UK it isn't
conceivable to me that we don't seek to
make sure we're making the next
generation of vehicles electric vehicles
here in the UK and fundamentally every
bit of public investment we're putting
forward is about leveraging in Greater
private investment that is the lesson
from what the Biden Administration has
done in the US I think the fact that the
UK has the lowest rate of business
investment in the G7 is a disgrace and
fixing that is not just about public
money it's about planning reform
regulatory reform fixing the skills
pipeline through the changes we'd make
to things like the apprenticeship let me
but it will require in some particular
cases and gigafactories for battery
production is a good example a degree of
public investment to do that but we also
know very clearly that the longer term
costs of not acting on Net Zero and
climate change will be greater than
doing what is required now but
fundamentally the difference between
ourselves and the conservative party is
about getting the good economic benefits
to the UK that should flow from that I
think people would agree with that
overall thing I think it's just the
question mark about the scale of what's
being invested uh and whether or not
it's worth it in when you look at the
number of jobs that will be created 28
billion pounds a year and obviously
without wanting to play Down the
importance of environmental projects you
know some might say when public finances
are tight shouldn't some of that
investment be spent on other capital
projects whether it's hospitals housing
schools not directly linked to the green
agenda what would you say to that
looks like that's done a lot and the
fact is many public services in this
country are in a state I mean there are
no Public Services working better today
than when the conservative party came to
power in 2010 but I have to say that if
you look at the root of that for me it
is the fact we are paying relatively
high levels of taxation by historical
levels because growth has been so low
over the last 13 years so I see fixing
the economy driving economic growth good
jobs in all parts of the country that's
not being an alternative or a competing
demand compared to funding Public
Services I've seen as being absolutely
essential to be able to provide the
funding for those Public Services over
the long term I mean we are an aging
Society our pensions bill goes up by
about six billion pounds a year in real
terms every year unless you've got an
economy that is growing at faster than
1.4 which is the average it's been since
the conservatives came back to Power
you're not going to be able to pay for
that so getting the economy fixed moving
in a more prosperous Direction becoming
one of the best performing economies in
the G7 rather than one of the worst
that's got to be integral to fixing all
the other problems in the country and
the big story around the world is about
clean energy it is about Net Zero it is
about the economic benefits that we need
to gain for the UK from following that
path and that's why it is the
centerpiece of our economic strategy
we'll be talking later on the show to
Gary Smith at the GMB Union he's pretty
unhappy with your party's plan to end
North Sea oil and gas licenses I mean if
you are all about jobs isn't that a bad
idea
well let's let's take this through the
components of the argument so first of
all the existing oil and gas fields in
the North Sea will run up right until
2050. we're not talking about turning
those off or ending that we are against
further new licenses being granted and
that's because it won't do anything for
bills it won't do anything for energy
security it's not a long-term answer to
jobs and clearly it would be a climate
disaster and it requires a few vast
amounts of public money in the form of
subsidy and allowances to make these
fields economic and attractive now I
understand because I I live and
represent part of East Manchester here
where I'm doing this interview from a
greater Manchester United a group in the
Northeast in the coal fields of County
Durham so I understand in the past this
country has done economic transitions
very badly and I think Gary is
absolutely right to defend and
strengthen the arguments for his members
to make sure they've got the the
opportunities they need going forward
because these existing Fields will run
until 2050 no one is going to be losing
their jobs within there but we've got to
understand that the opportunity in front
of us the number of jobs created from
clean energy is far in excess of the
existing directly employed Workforce in
North Sea oil and gas so it's not some
sort of consolation price this is the
big prize this is the big chance to do
that and we'll work with Gary to make
sure finally this country gets his
transition well I know that I haven't
got long left uh with you before you
need to leave and there are another
important questions I do want to get to
because the labor MPE Grant Davis has
been suspended from the labor party
after serious allegations of
unacceptable Behavior this was uncovered
by police case Aggie chambra now Sky
News understands that the labor party
whips office was made aware of the
allegations months ago but didn't take
action is that right
I don't know the answer to that question
what I can tell you is I've been part as
an NEC member of overhauling the labor
party's uh processes across a whole
range of disciplinary matters we've
tried and done a huge amount of work to
improve it to put Independence for any
kind of political considerations as part
of that and I would urge anyone to have
confidence in that process and come
forward of course we will always keep
that under review and try and make it as
effective as it needs to be and there's
always more work to do but I can I can
promise people we've done a great amount
of work to try and improve how we
respond to this as a political party and
a big difference between ourselves and
the conservatives is when something goes
wrong with the labor MP every time I see
it we take immediate action to suspend
the weapon fulfill the processes that we
put forward and do it in the proper
manner
I was really shocked by an interview
that I heard earlier this week with the
labor MP Charlotte Nichols she said that
when she was first elected in 2019 she
was given a list of 30 MPS to not accept
a drink from to not get in a car with to
effectively watch out for their behavior
30 MPS I mean I had to check that that
wasn't a typo
how bad are things in Westminster
well I'm horrified by a story like that
that anyone would would first of all
have to be told that or that that
sentiment would even exist the fact that
we have done such a significant amount
of work in the labor party to try and
make sure our processes are better than
they've been in the past reflects the
need to operate to the highest standards
possible and you know there are many
people again who are horrified by this
and we're trying to improve that process
it feels to me like you're talking about
the processes that have been improved
the processes can't improved that much
if serious allegations you know I I'm
careful about what I say here serious
allegations about an MP have only come
to light because of the work of
journalists it's not coming to light
because of what your party's doing
talking to people within it finding out
what's going on what's the evidence that
any of these processes are actually
making any difference at all
I think they are and I think they are
the kind of process which can give
people confidence because it's an
attempt to take out what I think people
have felt in the past which is there may
be some sort of political considerations
given to disciplinary action when the
effects matters of this kind we've tried
to remove that now look so there's a lot
of work to do and I understand we always
have to keep that under review and try
and do it better to respond to cases and
make sure in each case we can say this
has been as robust as it needs to be but
we have tried and I think if you look at
the immediate action the labor party
takes when any Member of Parliament or
elected representative has allegations
against them and has fallen potentially
below the standard required of them if
you look at the Swift action we take I
think that is the right approach I think
we haven't seen that always in the past
particularly from other political
parties we're trying to get it right and
we're always going to work until we can
have the absolute confidence we've got
the system and the processes in place
that we need
okay now we've got Jamie Driscoll on the
show later who's been barred from
standing as labor candidate for the
Northeast mayor now his supporters say
that this is all part of factionalism in
the labor party effectively kirstan were
trying to purge the left what would you
say to that
and I would strongly disagree with that
the labor party is a very large
organization which bigger I think still
than every other political party in
terms of membership added together but
case number has changed the leg party
since he became leader and part of that
process is we have a due diligence
process in place and that's because
frankly in the past not every person
elected as a labor representative has
met the standard required of them and
specifically
in a case where somebody shares a
platform with someone who themselves has
been expelled from the labor party for
their views are anti-Semitism for
opposing the turf action that needed to
happen that would preclude them from
being a labor candidate going forward
because when we said we'd have zero
tolerance of anti-Semitism and we said
we would tear it out from its roots we
were serious about that and I know
sometimes that will cause the rabbits
maybe not the expedient political thing
to do but we are absolutely serious
about sorting this problem out Kia storm
has made that absolutely clear and no
one should be surprised that we're
sticking to our word